lettuce is getting pricey no matter  where you shop so if you're missing your  greens here are five cheaper  alternatives to get your fix number one  kale it's great for smoothies sauces  salads and soups number two brussels  sprouts of course they're great roasted  or put into other casseroles but they're  also delicious shredded and eaten raw as  a salad number three broccoli of course  it's delicious roasted or stir-fried but  the stems are also really delicious If  you shred them and put them in a slaw  number four cabbage this is a season for  slaw and I'm never gonna be mad about it  but it's also really delicious braised  or stir-fried and finally bok choy it's  delicious in a stir fry but it's also  really great if you chop it up really  fine and throw it in a salad raw see  lettuce doesn't need to be the only way  to get your greens fixed so leave me a  comment below some of your favorite  hacks